als erste willkommen zu einem neuen
alten format ich hab mir folgendes
überlegt wie ihr seht sind wir gerade
hier in der pvp lobby auf lotte oliver
repp hobby aufgebahrt de punktet er da
vorne sich das renk best of 3 und ich
hab mir gedacht sebastian du hast das
doch damals ein format die ganz treuen
zuschauer werden sich noch an
road to top ten erinnern damals inländer
games das war ja ein relativ schwieriges
unterfangen aber jetzt gibt es neuen
spielmodus und ich habe mir gedacht wie
starten rote top ten neu im ranking
erstes von aufgaben hd und wir legen
direkt los am ende jeder folge wird es
auch tipps geben das heißt die kämpfe
die nicht so gut gelaufen sind werdet
ihr am ende der runde nummer
zusammengeschnitten sehen so kleinen
outtakes ist eine sehr coole idee die
ich zuallererst mal bei staffel gesehen
habe rote top ten
ich habe etwas angst stürmte top ist das
format bei ihm das hat er in chur kurs
gemacht und ich habe euch unten mal in
die beschreibung die playlist zu
reingepackt schaut da auch gerne mal
wieder diese autec idee cool findet wie
gesagt inspiration kommt davon dem
herren staffel
vielen dank dafür und wir legen jetzt
einfach mal los unser aktueller
rückstand beträgt 1240 und wir brauchen
für die top ten platzierung die das
erklärte ziel dieses projekts ist dieser
kleinen serie momentan mindestens 1709
elo also leute ich würde sagen
film ab und wir legen los mit dem ersten
duell liebe leute da sind wir gerade
machen wir schon eine runde hepp allein
aus der eventuell outtakes am ende
gesehen habt werdet hd pvp und jetzt
hier jetzt der erste sieg auch aufnahme
vielleicht bitte ja danke danke okay er
macht allen combo pvdf ein kommentar
er kriegt noch einen pfeil wird jetzt
noch ein noch ein hinter einer der song
angel angelika krebs aller unruhe der
schwede jetzt dann die machen da die
reine action und er kriegt noch okay es
das einmal richtig knapp
ach ja übrigens sollte im hintergrund
ist der raum hallo dessen channel ist
auch oben verlinkt in der beschreibung
ich habe mich daher zurück pendeln
format fest deckert zum zum festen
inventar dieses format stimme aus dem
hintergrund die stimme aus dem off und
ein cooler hund frisst egal
diese anleihe ist dann lass uns doch
einfach mal kämpfen wie wär's denn in
diesem format wir könnten kämpfen wir
könnten alle menschen könnten in pvp ok
ist er ist ein harter alle bands ich bin
halt eher so ein harter boden mensch der
aber jetzt keinen fall trafford egal
weiter weiter ok als hat auch die
sauerei macht mich fertig ob ich auf
keinen fall mehr legal übertreibt ok
krass heftig egal rematch jetzt geht es
um alles
now it goes around everything diese
allein macht mich fertig bei dem typen
dass das macht ihr euch um mich zu
verunsichern
er weiß aber dass niemand diese eine
leihe abbauen kann
so jetzt aber hier kriegt man schon
ersten schwert und einen ersten bogen
mit noch ich werdet ihr jetzt sagen
jetzt ist ein gekämpft ob er da raus
kommt ich glaube es nicht er kommt nicht
raus kommt nicht raus und er ist sehr
schön
erste windows 7 direkt los wir spielen
jetzt gegen den werten doubleface es
hier und die tatsache dass die runde
direkt los ging kann eigentlich nichts
gutes heißt das heißt ist mindestens auf
unserem level wahrscheinlich sogar über
diesen märkten diese allerdings diesen
richtig fett was die angel angeht hier
richtig hart am angeln und auch spiele
auch alle sehr sehr taktisch laufen auch
sind sie nicht so schon ein bisschen weg
zu laufen hier
sofern das ihnen was bringt aber er hat
auch gut gefressen
wir kürzen ja okay es ist besser es wird
immer ein bisschen könig wenn es also an
den rand der map gehörig geführt so
jetzt ein bisschen abgekürzt die angelei
macht mich wahnsinnig
könnte ich auch immer veganen das gibt's
doch nicht
das gibt es einfach nicht leute ja 2000
jahre später
gott ist es so hat täglich gespielt das
ist so haas' täglich gespielt was der
gemacht alta badia ist das eklig eine
ewigkeit später auch hat alter von fritz
bitte es gibt sicher der gewinn des mit
dem haydn märz wäre ich mich das auf
alter mich das auf alltägliche man
spielen kann
junge junge junge ok jetzt habe ich
einen chip as8 das hat er die erste
runde gewonnen
ok alles klar
glock hatte wenig leistung ist eine
junge junge junge
das macht mich so fertig weil manche
können es übrigens gut einsetzen
das ist dann auch wieder wird das wieder
cool das kann nicht das feiern auch wenn
das gut einsetzen kann man diese
wirklich [ __ ] müssten die nervigen
max zählt auf darunter max gerne mal
genauso wie seinen bogen wird das gut
hier guckt er doch zumindest nicht weg
der fighter zumindest das ist gut alle
grad ebene ich bin ich auf dieser
kleinen mehr blogger locker 45 minuten
hinterher gelaufen alter schwede
jetzt steht herum nutze ich die
gelegenheit mal um gegen den jungen
herren zu kämpfen
alle sind wir alle wissen so angl
spammen spam rino mathis frist du bist
nicht sehr schön und wieder 20 go go go
go on the way to the top
ja volle kanne aber geht schon so kommt
nein nein nein es dauernd mit meinem
letzten pfeil alter schwede
diese combo aus angel und roger angel
und trotz mangel und ostbayern macht am
ende einfach richtig fertig das geht
richtig an die substanz
alter schwede ok und der spielmodus
einlegt hat auch einfach wie teilweise
sind okay und es dauern
alter schwede gg
mein lieber jung soo leute damit haben
wir jetzt hier 1300 elo geholt sie macht
vielleicht einfach mal so immer hunderte
pro folge soll dass das so als benchmark
1300 bis zur top ten platzierung fehlen
noch 400 und 900 419 und binya verlangen
wollen ich würde sagen es geht sehr gut
voran welches format gefällt das gerne
daumen nach oben da wir sind zum
nächsten video wieder raul ist eine
probe sagt schick den apparat und ja und
jetzt die outtakes und hacker bin ich
okay band